so I've been thinking about how to
explain this concept to you and I've
decided I'm just gonna start with
something we all understand to achieve
great heights or change the world no
matter how smart we are we all need
people and for conventional people the
universe seems to conspire to make them
successful for the unconventional I
think we need something that I like to
call co-conspirators co-conspirators are
different not because they're different
themselves but because of the people who
need them they tend to be people who are
willing to bend the rules actually even
break them sometimes and challenge the
status quo to stand beside someone who's
going against societal norms I'm
actually gonna describe an experience
that I had that first crystallized the
idea of co-conspirators in my mind in
2014 I was a corporate executive with an
American multinational in India and we
were actually faced with an interesting
problem we didn't have enough women in
the workforce and just to give you some
context 27 percent of women work in
India if you look at most of Asia that
number is around 48% so we knew the
numbers were deplorable and it was
manifesting itself in our own
organization so we decided and actually
I'll just give you a quick example of a
young engineer a 25 year old woman who
told us a great story about her daily
life to just exemplify it for us she
said as I walk out of the house in the
morning I'm running around doing a bunch
of chores and my mother-in-law I live
with my in-laws are starting to get a
little bit it's starting to get a little
bit irritated because she's gonna be
left with all the housework to do and
then as I get back home in the evening
I've overshot the time I'm going to be
home by an hour or two at least
and by then two of my biggest champions
my father-in-law and my husband are also
starting to get a little bit irritated
and my mother-in-law's furious because
she's taking
care of everything that needs to be done
and through the middle of the day I'm
actually surrounded by men my age and
there's only one expectation from them
by society it's to achieve in their
careers and provide for their families
financially how do you expect me to
bring the same level of enthusiasm
excitement and passion to the workplace
and she was right and I thought the the
Women's Network volunteers came up with
a great idea they instituted a bring
your mother-in-law to work day so we
heralded a group of mothers in law and a
few mothers into the office and we took
them to our R&D labs and we took them to
the medical equipment that their
daughters-in-law
were creating and building and as we did
we described to them what their
daughters-in-law actually did they
impacted maternal mortality rates and
infant mortality rates they brought them
down they identified complex diseases
early enough to be able to prevent and
cure them and then we took them to lunch
we gave them a lavish lunch and thank
them for the role they played for
freeing up a young woman to work
shoulder-to-shoulder with us to
literally change the world there wasn't
a dry eye in the room every one of these
women were grateful and proud they were
proud of who their daughters-in-law were
but they were grateful to be included as
part of the conversation and I wondered
at the time whether what we'd done was
just a great touchy-feely moment and was
cute but really wasn't going to have
long-term impact and a couple of days
later one of my mentees swung by my
office and she was super excited she
said I went home from work yesterday and
I was bracing myself because I was
really late and I was bracing myself for
a lecture and my mother-in-law turned to
my husband and said can you please get
up and make her a cup of tea she's
exhausted she's saving lives you work at
a bank
and there you had it you had the perfect
co-conspirator someone that we don't
always recognize her value but was
changing the way somebody else could
challenge the status quo by
landing beside her and questioning the
societal norms and making a difference
the next example I'm going to use will
be closer to almost everyone in this
room we actually when I graduated from
business school and started working in a
company a group of us my peers and I
were asked to work on a strategy for a
business that hadn't been doing too well
over the last decade and was being
neglected we put our hearts and souls
into it and we did a lot of analysis on
our nights and weekends and put together
what we thought was a good strategy and
after presenting it to a number of
people that we were getting buy-in with
we were actually asked to present to the
global CEO at his annual strategy meet
that happened over a week and we were
both excited and apprehensive as we flew
into headquarters we were excited
because this was an opportunity to show
how much we had learned but we were also
nervous because though a brilliant
dynamic man he had a fiery temper and
wasn't really the easiest person to
present to five or six hours before our
presentation a senior colleague pulled
us aside and sat down and gave us a
front seat view of what had happened all
week we knew about people who had bombed
our presentations we knew about people
who'd almost been instantaneously
promoted in the room we knew what was
keeping the CEO up at night and what he
thought were tail winds to the business
and when we walked into that
presentation later in the day we
actually we actually got buy-in with
both the CEO and his senior staff and it
wasn't just because of our analysis or
our strategy it was because we were
prepped to be able to communicate in a
way that the team could absorb now the
senior colleague of ours didn't pull us
aside because he wanted to gossip he
pulled us aside because he believed we
were unconventional in the boardroom
that unconventionality was exactly why
he wanted us to think about this new
fresh perspective and provide a view on
where this business should go but he
also knew it was a distinct disadvantage
for us because we didn't know how to
present in that room and we hadn't done
it before and they weren't used to
receiving us and that again as an
example in my mind of somebody bending
the rules because he decided to Co
conspire with
he not only changed the career
trajectories of six people six young
people in the organization who suddenly
got all this visibility but he actually
changed the trajectory of a business
that people were neglecting and didn't
have any fresh ideas for the last
example I want to share with you is
actually very far removed from the
corporate world and somewhat personal
this is the story of my mother in her
early 20s she lost her father and he had
passed away in his late 40s leaving
behind six children four younger
siblings and one older sibling than her
and a widowed mother who had never
worked my mom and her older sister
realized that they actually needed to
start earning an income they were both
in grad school to be able to ensure the
rest of the siblings could get through
their schooling and start to work so she
shifted her law school classes to
evening classes and she started to work
during the day as a school teacher to
bring home an income and every day she
would actually get off a bus at the end
of her evening law school classes on the
streets of Calcutta now mind you this
was a woman who wasn't used to taking
public transportation at all let alone
at night and as she would get off the
bus she would take about a seven to
eight minute walk to her home from the
bus stop
on a street that were just largely
deserted because it was a residential
street with some shops that closed
around 8:00 p.m. or a little bit before
that one day a store owner who is
closing his store a little bit later
than usual because there was a customer
who had actually left a little bit later
and he saw my mother get off the bus he
waited for her he actually knew the
family they'd been in the neighborhood
for the store had been in the
neighborhood for more than 20 years so
he knew her since she was a baby he
watched her walk to her the street that
were her house was on shut this lights
turned off the lights shut the store and
went home from the next day he found
that he waited for her every single day
until she made her way to her own house
other store owners on that same street
suddenly noticed this one store that was
open longer and suddenly started to see
a bunch of end of
day customers walk in to buy odds and
ends that from after their long day of
work and their commute home realized
they hadn't picked up for the next
morning some people who came in the
mornings also started to come the night
before a few of the store keepers
decided that actually what was happening
as he was monopolizing a bunch of
customers and they started to keep their
store lights on and keep their shops
open till nine o'clock
from that time on my mother had a lit
Street with plenty of activity on the
street I believe that that store owner
was my mother's co-conspirator because
of him a small change to what was
conventional on that Street at the time
allowed for her and her family to do
something that was completely
unconventional a woman her age
from an upper middle-class family
actually got married at that age or
studied in grad school with the
protection of their family because of
that store owner all of my mother's
siblings went on to become engineers
lawyers accountants and teachers and my
mother went on to become a lawyer
the world needs co-conspirators as we
get into a complex environment where
more and more complex problems exist and
we need to find more solutions we need
unconventional people in our boardrooms
and at the table for that to happen we
need co-conspirators in my own life
whether it's because of my gender my
ethnicity or sometimes as I've been
living in this part of the world for
over a decade my accent I'm often
perceived to be unconventional it's my
co-conspirators that have shown me the
path forward and actually it's my
co-conspirators kid that keep me seeking
out the unconventional paths to go down
so what I'd like to ask of all of you
today is that you look around and find
the people that inspire you to Co
conspire I promise you that your empathy
and your courage will change someone's
life and may even change the world thank
you
[Applause]